bob nightingale covers the sport as well
as anybody major league baseball
usa today columnist and the marlins have
put the sport
in jeopardy and bob joins us now what's
the next step
in this situation bob i don't think
baseball even knows i mean better game
got canceled today with the brewers in
st louis cardinals
with two cardinal players testing
positive this is big for baseball
because now they're the first team
to have players test positive since our
marlins last week
the marlins have like 18 or 19 of the 30
guys already sidelined because of
positive tests
do we know how they came up with all
these guys testing positive with the
marlins
we don't and major league baseball's
looking into it so are the marlins
something
something strange happened i mean
certainly it seemed like it happened
atlanta
where they had the two exhibition games
before flying in philadelphia
but just a huge outbreak so apparently
someone got
uh positive in atlanta then they're on a
team plane
and then boom widespread but did you
allude to them maybe going out on the
town
or at least one of the players was
partying in atlanta
i don't know about partying but at least
one or two guys went out
atlanta it could have been out to dinner
could be something innocent
but left the hotel and i think baseball
now that's why they've cracked down
and say hey when you're on the road
you're not going anywhere you're not
even going to the
hotel restaurant or grabbing a nightcap
at the hotel bar
straight back to the room or a little
private dining room but somebody went on
atlanta
i don't understand you know that
baseball is sort of looking at this
going okay
now what is next not they're not going
to play 60 games
and and some of these other teams aren't
going to play 60 games bob i know the
goal is just to get to the postseason so
the owners can
make some money back but how are they
going to decide who goes into the
postseason
if if it's not a balanced schedule by
these teams
i think that no choice dan but go by
winning percentage i mean right now the
marlins are two on one
maybe they get to be in the playoffs the
first time in ages
yeah it's a mess you know one time dan
in spring training
or when this thing first got shut down
baseball was considering
worst comes the worst just a a
tournament like a march madness
tournament baseball style
you know maybe they're going to have to
resort to that because
like you said the big thing was just to
have the post season that post season is
worth
about 800 million dollars what happens
like for the next shoe to drop in
baseball would do something dramatic
what would have to happen considering
all these games that are being canceled
now
that aren't even marlins related
yeah i think just more and more games
are canceled they're gonna have to you
know no choice but to suspend it at one
point
and let's be honest if this was the
yankees had you know 18
guys test positive the dodgers the cubs
the sport would have been shut down for
weeks
but some marlins like okay they're not
supposed to be competitive anyway
you hate to say that but if one of the
big boys had gone down
then i think they'd have no choice but
let's spend the season for a couple
weeks
and pick it up pick it back up i agree
with you the fact it's the marlins and
we go oh it's the marlins but if this
had been the yankees of the dodgers this
would be front page news this would be
huge is there a chance that the
commissioner just says to the marlins
thanks uh we've got some nice parting
gifts for you but
you're uh bringing down the sport here
boys
well they're very upset you know living
with the marlins
they're having a compliance officer now
travel with teams
now you're supposed to wear the hospital
mask instead of by the cloth mess
uh you know it's possible they could do
that but hey you have the taxi squad for
a reason
that's why they have the extra 30
players and considering some marlins you
know
it shouldn't be that big of a drop-off
you're right we're talking to bob
nightingale the baseball columnist for
usa today
i'm looking at the memorabilia back
there is that a bo jackson
football jersey it is from auburn days
nice what's the best piece of
memorabilia you have there in the uh
house
i've got a yogi bear jersey that's
pretty cool
and i uh my favorite basketball player
dr j so i have a doctor jay jersey
too from sixers i wish i had it for the
nets but yeah
so i like those you know when you tell
people about bo jackson
and it almost he takes on like this
superhero like this comic book character
type persona that people can't believe
that somebody was that good
if he had stuck with baseball bob and
been healthy because he got injured
playing football but if he had stuck
with
just baseball what kind of career do you
think bo jackson would have turned in
you know i don't know if it would have
been a hall of fame type career dan but
it would have been a multi-multiple
all-star type career
where he'd be a guy like okay is he
going the hall of fame or not
you know i was lucky i got to cover him
as soon as he broke in with the royals
this guy would just do crazy stuff in
the clubhouse say hey 10 bucks i can
jump over this table
arrow shooting up here he said you know
i believe he could have done anything
you know
gymnastics swimming the only thing he
said he couldn't do was basketball
he says i yeah he was i can't dribble i
can't dribble but anything else
he would have been an all-american
whatever he wanted to do as far as
athletes to cover
how would you compare him to dion
sanders in baseball and maybe somebody
else uh
being a great athlete in baseball
well i would say bo is number one but
you know partial because i covered him
was with him
every day and let's be honest beau did
not like dion
at all you know dion was very flashy bo
was not
bo you know of all of his
accomplishments i think the biggest
accomplishment was overcoming that
stuttering problem
it was as bad as starting problem as
anybody i've ever been around he went to
speech therapy and everything else
amazing what he's done because you know
i remember sitting down with him early
after first couple weeks of uh
joining the royals and he says hey
people say i say bonos or you know talk
beau is the third person as an arrogant
he goes no
i can't say the word i without
stuttering so that's how the whole book
oh wow
wow i did not know that yeah uh let me
leave you with this
joe kelly is appealing his suspension
the likelihood of that being reduced is
what
uh i'd say about a hundred percent you
know that's you know eight games is
equivalent of what 22.7 normal season
i think to reduce it to five games the
bottom line is
baseball was livid over that just the
fact it could have been a complete
nightmare
if her brawl had broken out who have on
every news channel across the world
you know guys spreading cove and stuff
like that wrestling in the ground
was our big fear like hey if there's any
other season
go ahead you got a free pass not this
season but i i also wonder if
you gave the commissioner a mulligan to
punish the astros
a could he have punished the astros
given the battle with the players
association
and b would he have would he have
attempted that battle
i don't think so i just i don't think he
would have got any cooperation
i mean the bottom line is if there
wasn't a whistleblower
mike fires i'm not sure anything comes
out i mean nothing happened with the red
sox
yankees other teams investigated but the
fact they had one guy
come out and the astro players got in
unity
so they say yeah what he said is correct
unfortunately he's right
i think if these guys have not got
immunity everybody would have clammed up
or
just really probably so um
mike trout with the uh paternity leave
uh
he i didn't know there's a paternity uh
list
that that uh you can be put on but so
trout can come and go
depending on getting tested
and testing negative well you have a
returning list for three days
you're supposed to get three days with
pay now a team can give you a longer
period of time
and still pay you which i'm sure this is
the case uh the baby is supposed to be
born
april i mean uh august 3rd which is
monday so i think you want to be very
cautious and has my firstborn
uh i do not want to miss this birth i
want to stay pop you know stay negative
test wise
so i'd be surprised if he's back right
away i could see him missing a week
at least being around the baby for a
little bit and i think the angels would
certainly understand and said take as
much time as you need
you know we need your back really
baseball needs them back
as scott morris signed mike trout's baby
yet
well greg lannister's asia got him
locked up so he's oh okay
all right right no 10 or 11 years left
so
uh hey it's great to talk to you bob
thanks for joining us
thank you dad all right bob nightgale
usa today